UPDATE TRAVEL GUIDANCE SHORTLY.
SO MAYBE WE’LL HEAR SOMETHING
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT ARE VACCINATED
BEING ABLE TO TAKE OFF THE MASK.
LET’S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
AND WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT FULLY VACCINATED
PEOPLE CAN GO MASK WILL SCAN
MANY SITUATIONS?
IT’S ABOUT TIME, THAT WE
SHOULDN’T BE NOT BE PLAYING
POLITICS AND FROM THE BEGINNING
OF COVID THERE’S BEEN FAR TOO
MUCH POLITICS CONNECTED TO IT.
THE EXTREME ON EITHER SIDE, AND
I WOULD NEVER WEAR A MASK ON AN
AIRPLANE AND KIT SHOULD BE IN
SCHOOL IN PERSON TODAY IN THE
SCIENCE IS UNEQUIVOCAL ON THAT.
THEY WERE ALSO PLAYING POLITICS
ON MASKS, THAT IT NEVER MADE ANY
SENSE ONCE YOU ARE VACCINATED TO
WEAR A MASK AND UNFORTUNATELY
BIDEN AND HARRIS KEPT SAYING
WEAR A MASK, WEAR A MASK, AND
AND STOP THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE AND IT OUGHT TO BE
VOLUNTARY.
YOU SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO GET
THE VACCINE AND ONE OF THE GREAT
VIRTUES WHEN YOU GET THE
VACCINE, YOU CAN TAKE THE MASK
OFF AND RETURN TO REGULAR LIFE
AND THAT SHOULD ENCOURAGE MORE
PEOPLE TO GET THE VACCINE.
>> Sandra: WE ARE THANKFUL THE
MASK HELPED US WHEN THEY NEEDED
THEM AND WE ARE ALSO THANKFUL
FOR THAT MANY AMERICANS WILL BE
THANKFUL FOR THE DAY WHEN WE CAN
PUT THEM DOWN.
SENATOR, TWO HOURS AGO IT STRUCK
ME, A TWEET THAT YOU PUT OUT.
FOUR MONTHS INTO THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY AND WE ALREADY HAVE,
AND YOU CHECKED OFF AT A BORDER
CRISIS, A GAS CRISIS AND A
MIDDLE OR IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THE
POLITICS OF THIS MOMENT.
>> THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN
THE MOST RADICAL OF ANY
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY JOE BIDEN HAS
DECIDED TO HAND OVER THE AGENDA
TO THE EXTREME LEFT IN THIS
PARTY SO THE PEOPLE DRIVING THE
SUBSTANCE ARE BERNIE SANDERS,
ELIZABETH WARREN AND AOC AND WE
ARE SEEING $6 TRILLION IN NEW
TAXES PROPOSED, WE ARE SEEING
THE BORDER, ABSOLUTE CHAOS, THE
WORST IN 20 YEARS AND IT’S
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS WANT
TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
AND WE ARE SEEING DOMESTICALLY A
CRISIS.
WE ARE SEEING ECONOMICALLY A
CRISIS AND THE INFLATION THAT IS
COMING.
AND WHEN YOU SPEND $6 TRILLION
WE DON’T HAVE ANY PRINT THE
MONEY YOU CREATE INFLATION.
I’M NOT ABROAD, IN JUST A FEW
MONTHS BIDEN HAS MANAGED TO
UNDERMINE OUR FRIENDS AND ALLIES
TO UNDERMINE ISRAEL AND SEND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY’S
AND HAMAS AND PROMISE THE
AYATOLLAH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHAT’S A REWARD FOR THAT?
HAMAS IS RAINING ROCKETS ON
ISRAEL WITH MONEY THAT COMES,
AND WE ARE SEEING CRISIS AFTER
CRISIS AFTER CRISIS BECAUSE THE
BIDEN-HARRIS POLICIES ARE
RADICAL AND EXTREME THAT THEY
DON’T WORK.
>> John: SENATOR, WE ARE JUST
GETTING SOME NEWS IN FROM OUR
JERUSALEM FOXBOROUGH AND IT MAY
NOT JUST BE HAMAS THAT IS
RAINING ROCKETS DOWN ON ISRAEL.
DEVORAH LENSKI REPORTS THAT
ROCKETS HAVE BEEN FIRED INTO
ISRAEL FROM LEBANON’S TERRITORY.
IT HAS THE LAW WHICH IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY IRAN IS NOW GETTING
INVOLVED, WHERE COULD THIS GO?
WE ARE REFLECTING IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
AMERICA STANDS UNEQUIVOCALLY
WITH ISRAEL AND WE’VE MOVED OUR
EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM, I WAS
THERE THE DAY WE OPENED OUR
EMBASSY.
WE PULLED OUT OF THE DISASTROUS
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL AND SOMETHING
ELSE THAT I URGE THE PRESIDENT
TO DO.
IT PRODUCED THIS INCREDIBLE
BLOSSOMING, THIS FLOWERING OF
PEACE AND IT PRODUCED THE
ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
I SPOKE WITH THE FOREIGN
MINISTERS AND AMBASSADORS OF
BAHRAIN AND UAE WHEN THE ABRAHAM
WERE ASSIGNED AND THEY SAID IT’S
CLEAR THAT AMERICA STANDS
UNEQUIVOCALLY WITH ISRAEL.
WE WANT TO BE FRIENDS WITH
AMERICA, SO THEREFORE WE WILL BE
FRIENDS WITH ISRAEL AND THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT I URGE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IF WE ARE CLEAR AND THERE IS NO
AMBIGUITY, WE WILL MAKE IT
FRIENDS TO ENEMIES AS WE STAND.
WE THERE IS AN ACT WE PASSED
CALLED THE TAYLOR FOR SOCK.
TAYLOR FORCE ACT.
HE WAS KILLED BY TERRORISTS IN
ISRAEL AND HAMAS SINCE MONEY
EVERY YEAR TO THE FAMILIES OF
THE TERRORISTS WHO MURDER
AMERICANS AND MURDER ISRAELIS.
THE TAYLOR FORCE ACT SAYS WE
WON’T SEND TAXPAYER MONEY TO ANY
GOVERNMENT OR ANY ORGANIZATION
WHO PAYS TERRORISTS TO MURDER
AMERICANS AND MURDER OUR ALLIES.
JOE BIDEN DECIDED TO IGNORE THAT
LAW, VIOLATE THAT LAW AND SO HE
HAS RESUMED SENDING OVER
$100 MILLION TO THE PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITY, AND TO HAMAS, THAT
LESSON IS NOT LOST ON ANY OF THE
TERRORISTS AND RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE RAINING ROCKETS DOWN ON
ISRAEL WITH IMPUNITY BECAUSE
THEY DON’T BELIEVE JOE BIDEN OR
KAMALA HARRIS WILL DO A SINGLE
THING ABOUT IT.
>> Sandra: I WONDER WHAT YOUR
MESSAGES TO THOSE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO ARE CRITICIZING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT FOR
STANDING WITH ISRAEL, AND ALSO
RASHIDA TLAIB, ANOTHER MEMBER OF
THE SO-CALLED SQUAD CLAIMING
ISRAEL IS REPORTING RACISM AND
DEHUMANIZATION UNDER APARTHEID
SYSTEMS.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THAT IS THE
DRIVING FORCE IN TODAY’S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT’S THE ANGRY SOCIALIST LEFT.
AOC AND RASHIDA TLAIB AND
ILHAN OMAR WERE TWEETING THINGS
THAT ARE FRANKLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM WHAT THEY
HAVE WOULD BE SAYING IF THEY
WERE ACTUALLY THE PRESS
SECRETARY AND I’M REMINDED OF
SOMETHING THAT PRIME MINISTER
NETANYAHU SET A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO, AND OVER THE YEARS
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU AND I
HAVE BECOME GOOD FRIENDS.
HE MADE THE FOLLOWING
OBSERVATION.
HE SAID IN ISRAEL YOU USE THE
MISSILES TO DEFEND OUR CITIZENS.
HAMAS USES THE CITIZEN TO DEFEND
OUR MISSILES AND THEY ARE
LITERALLY USING PALESTINIAN
CHILDREN AS HUMAN SHIELDS THAT
THEY WANT TO MURDER ISRAELI
CHILDREN WITH.
THEY HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS THAT
BASICALLY OPERATE AS SHILLS FOR
TERRORISTS, AND AND AFTER A
WHILE, WE SAY, IT’S NOT SUBTLE
AND IT’S UGLY TO SEE IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
>> John: WE ARE GETTING AN
UPDATE ON WHAT I TOLD YOU A
MOMENT AGO ABOUT ROCKETS BEING
FIRED AND WE DON’T KNOW WHICH
TOWN IT IS, THREE ROCKETS WERE
FIRED, APPARENTLY NO CASUALTIES.
LET ME JUST SWITCHED IF I COULD
TO THE GAS SHORTAGE AND, THE
THING WITH THE PIPELINE DIDN’T
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
IT MIGHT AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE, AND WITH JUST A SINGLE
PUSH OF THE BUTTON.
>> IF THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
THERE ARE REAL THREATS TO THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CYBER ATTACKS FROM RUSSIA,
CHINA, IRAN AND NORTH KOREA.
WE NEED TO DO MUCH MORE TO
SECURE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN CONNECTION WITH THE A
GREEN NEW DEAL, IT IS A VISION
THAT ON DAY ONE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE THE JOE BIDEN SHUT
DOWN THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING TO
SHUT DOWN THE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IN THE UNITED STATES
AND WE ARE GETTING A
FORESHADOWING OF WHAT THE WORLD
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS LIKE,
SHUTTING DOWN ONE PIPELINE AND
SUDDENLY PEOPLE CAN’T GET GAS TO
PUT IN THEIR CARS TO GO TO WORK.
THAT’S JUST ONE PIPELINE.
THIS IS WHAT BIDEN AND PELOSI
ARE TRYING TO DO FOR THE COUNTRY
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO BE INSTEAD OF
EXPANDING AMERICAN ENERGY AND
INDEPENDENCE.
TODAY AMERICA IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRODUCER OF OIL IN THE WORLD AND
THE NUMBER ONE PRODUCER OF
NATURAL GAS.
THAT CHANGES THE GEOPOLITICAL
CHESSBOARD WHICH USED TO BE
DEPENDENT ON THE MIDDLE EAST FOR
OIL AND GAS AND NOW WE ARE THE
ENERGY SUPERPOWER.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
TRYING TO MESS THAT UP.
LET ME SAY ONE OTHER THING ALSO,
ONE OF THE REAL CHALLENGES
ISRAEL FACES RIGHT NOW IS THERE
IRON DOME WAS, THE INTERCEPTORS,
ARE TAKING OUT THESE ROCKETS ONE
AFTER THE OTHER AFTER THE OTHER.
I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING
JOE BIDEN COULD DO TODAY TO SHOW
A DECISIVE PRESIDENTIAL
LEADERSHIP, HE COULD STAND UP
AND SAY WE ARE GOING TO
REPLENISH ISRAEL’S IRON DOME
MISSILES.
THESE MISSILES ARE NEVER AIMED
AT PEOPLE, THEY ARE AIMED AT
INCOMING ROCKETS THAT ARE TRYING
TO AND THAT’S AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF IRON DOME MISSILES.
>> Sandra: FINALLY FROM THE
CRISIS IN THE MIDDLE EAST TO THE
ONGOING CRISIS IN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, IT’S BEEN 50 DAYS NOW
AND COUNTING THAT KAMALA HARRIS
HAS BEEN PUT IN CHARGE OF THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER.
SHE HASN’T HELD A NEWS
CONFERENCE OR VISITED THE BORDER
BUT I KNOW YOU ARE CALLING IT AT
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN NEXT AND, IF
SHE CONTINUES TO IGNORE THE
SITUATION OR NOT VISIT THE
BORDER OR NOT HOLD A NEWS
CONFERENCE, HOW ABOUT DOES IT
GET?
>> THERE IS ZERO LEADERSHIP
RIGHT NOW TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THE APPROACH OF JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS IS TO PRETEND THAT
THE CRISIS DOESN’T EXIST.
WE BROUGHT A GROUP OF 19
SENATORS DOWN OVER THE BORDER TO
SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT’S HAPPENING.
I’VE BEEN TO THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY MANY TIMES REPRESENTING
THE STATE OF TEXAS AND I’VE SEEN
NEVER SEEN IT REMOTELY THIS BAD.
EVERY MONTH IS HIGHER THAN THE
MONTH BEFORE, AND WE ARE ON A
PATH TO SEE HOW MANY 2 MILLION
PEOPLE HERE ARE COMING ILLEGALLY
ILLEGALLY.
WE HAVE PEOPLE PACKED IN
OVERCAPACITY CAGES AND ABIDING
CAGES ON BIGGER AND MORE FULL
THAN THEY’VE EVER BEEN IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC WHERE COVERT
POSITIVITY IS OVER 10%.
IF SOMEONE PUT KAMALA HARRIS IN
CHARGE OF A HOT DOG STAND ENDED
50/50 DAYS, SHE’S DONE NOTHING.
SHE LITERALLY WENT TO THE
CANADIAN BORDER IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
BEFORE SHE’S GONE TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
I JOKED, LAST I CHECKED THERE
ARE NOT THOUSANDS OF CANUCKS
STREAMING ACROSS OUR NORTHERN
BORDER.
AND THERE IS A REASON SANDRA
THAT NEITHER BIDEN NOR HARRIS
WANT TO GO TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, BECAUSE IF THEY KNOW IF
THEY COME THAT TV CAMERAS WILL
FOLLOW.
AND THEY CAN’T SOLVE THE PROBLEM
PROBLEM.
THE WAY THEY SOLVE THE PROBLEM
IS TO RESULT IN BUILDING THE
WALL AND RETURN TO THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY, AND A SUCCESSFUL
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEGOTIATED THAT
RESULTED IN LAST YEAR WE HAVE
THE LOWEST RATE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IN 45 YEARS.
PAUSE AND REFLECT ON THAT.
WE KNOW HOW TO SUCCEED IN THIS
BECAUSE LAST YEAR, REMAIN IN
MEXICO PRODUCED THE LOWEST RATES
IN 45 YEARS.
JOE BIDEN IN THIS VERSE WEEK IN
OFFICE WRITTEN AND INTERNATIONAL
AGREEMENT TO PIECES AND IT WAS
CAUSING THIS VALUE.
THE REASON THAT VITAMIN-HERE IS
GOING TO COMING FROM IS FAR LESS
RADICAL ACTIVISTS THAN THEY WANT
GIVEN THAT, THERE IS NO SOLUTION
TO THIS CRISIS UNTIL THEY ADMIT
THEIR POLICIES ARE WRONG AND
THAT THEY ARE HURTING PEOPLE.
IT’S NOT HUMANE.
CHILDREN ARE LEAVING THE FAMILY
IS ON THE INCOME IS WOMEN ARE
BEING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED, AND
DISEASE AND RUNNING.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
AND IT IS JOE BIDEN AND HIS
DECISIONS THAT HAVE CAUSED.
>> Sandra: IT’S A LOT.
IT’S A LOT HAPPENING AT A LOT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEE